oh maybe there was a key over by the
lantern that I didn't see probably
behind a box or something oh oh oh look
at this tiny box oh it's so tiny oh I'm
gonna call you tiny box Tim you're gonna
come with me on an adventure tiny box
Tim maybe I gotta smash you open in the
keys inside you know I know you I would
never hurt you my little biscuit okay
still haven't found the key
you smell a key around here do you smell
key behind those boxes the boxes that
bullied you because you're smaller yeah
kill them
jo no booth oh maybe there's a spare key
or crowbar in the storage area is it
dangerous
Thank You tiny box Tim have to finish
this you guard the demons from coming
back for me Thank You Tommy bucks Tim I
was always thinking of you even in the
darkest of times
[Music]
tiny box telling Hamid just a month
actually you go scout ahead dangerous
[Music]
and even attempted the old Bloody Mary
trick in the mirror you stretching Yard
deciding that you will always be my best
friends